[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا في حصاد الليله معكم
حسن جم
وفي الوقت الذي احدثكم فيه تقع احداث
وتتفاعل اخرى البدايه من موسكو حيث بدا
الرئيس الصيني زياره دوله الى روسيا تستمر
ثلاثه ايام
من موسكو الى واشنطن والاعلان عن مساعده
عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه 300
مليون دولار
وناخذكم الى باريس حيث اعتمد تعديل نظام
التقاعد بشكل نهائي بعد اخفاق المعارضه في
حجب الثقه عن حكومه اليزابيث
وفي مواضيع الحصاد لهذه الليله
في قمه موسكو بوتين يبلغ شيتش برغبته في
نقاش خطه الصين للسلام في اوكرانيا
والرئيس الصيني يشيد بما اعتبره تعونا
استراتيجيا شاملا بين موسكو وبيجين وفي
ردود الفعل واشنطن تقول ان على العالم ان
لا ينخدع لمقترحات الرئيس الصيني في موسكو
قبل اكتمال الشهر الثالث عشر لحرب روسيا
على اوكرانيا الاتحاد الاوروبي يقر خطه
بقيمه مليار يورو لتزويد
حزمه مساعدات عسكريه امريكيه جديده
لاوكرانيا بقيمه 350 مليون دولار وفي
تطورات الميدان رئيس فاجنر يعلن سيطره
مقاتليه على نحو 70% من باخموت
[موسيقى]
ردود فعل غاضب بعد تصريحات لوزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي عن عدم وجود شعب فلسطيني
واستخدامه خريطه لاسرائيل تضم المملكه
الاردنيه السلطه الفلسطينيه تعتبر
التصريحات دليلا على عنصريه حكومه نتنياهو
حركه حماس تقول ان حديث
يكشف العقيده السياسيه للكيان الاسرائيلي
والاردن يعتبر تصرفات سموتريتش وتصريحاته
عنصريه تحريضيه ومتطرفه ويستدعي السفير
الاسرائيلي
الازمه التونسيه على جنده اجتماع وزراء
خارجيه الاتحاد الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل يصف
الوضع الاقتصادي وسياسيه بالسيء للغايه
ويقلل من فرص حصول تونس على قرض من صندوق
النقد
لامكاني يؤكد التزام واشنطن بدعم حوار
سياسي شامل وانصار الرئيس التونسي
يتظاهرون في العاصمه لدعمه والتنديد بما
اعتبروه التدخلا اجنبيا
مشاهدينا في لقائنا اليومي قبل الحصاد على
منصاتنا الرقميه
ناقشنا ردود الفعل في السودان وافاق
الازمه بعد الاعلان عن الجدول الزمني
لتوقيع الاتفاق النهائي والدستور
الانتقالي وتشكيل مؤسسات السلطه
الانتقاليه
لاستطلاع ارائكم بشان هذا الموضوع كنا قد
طرحنا عليكم السؤال التالي برايكم المتوقع
بعد اعلان الجدول الزمني للمحطات الاخيره
في العمليات السياسيه بالسودان جاءت
الاجابات على النحو التالي 17% صوت لصالح
اكتمال التحول الديمقراطي بينما ذهب اربعه
واربعون في المئه باتجاه امكانيه مزيد من
التعقيد في الازمه في حين قالت
39% ان الازمه ستراوح مكانها
هذا السؤال سيبقى مطروحا على منصاتنا
الرقميه ويمكنكم دخول صفحه التصويت عبر
مسح رمز كيو ار الظاهر على الشاشه لقائنا
على المنصات الرقميه يتجدد يوميا ونتطرق
خلاله لقضايا مستجده ومتفاعله عربيه
ودوليا
وتتابعون في الحصاد ايضا
وسجد سياسيا وغضب شعبي اعتماد قانون تعديل
نظام التقاعد في فرنسا بعد رفض البرلمان
مقترحي حجم الثقه عن الحكومه
[موسيقى]
قال الرئيس الروسي فلاديمير بوتين بلاده
تدرس باهتمام خطه التسويه التي اقترحتها
الصين حول الوضع في اوكرانيا ووصف بوتين
في لقاء جمعه بنظيره صيني
في موسكو المواقف الصينيه بالمتوازنه في
القضايا الاقليميه والدوليه بدوره قال
الرئيس الصيني ان بلاده مهتمه بتطوير
العلاقه مع روسيا واصفا اياها بالشريك
الاستراتيجي ومشيرا الى ان البلدين لديهما
اهداف متشابهه
[موسيقى]
هو اللقاء الحادي والاربعون بين الرئيسين
الصيني والروسي على مدى عقد من الزمن
موسكو كانت مجددا خيار شيجين بينج لتكون
اول وجهه خارجيه له بعد اعاده انتخابه
زعيما للصين
[موسيقى]
تو الاهتماما كبيرا لتطوير العلاقات
الصينيه الروسيه بحكم ان في هذا الامر
منطقا تاريخيا وبحكم اننا اكبر الدول
الجوار ونحن شركاء في التعاون الاستراتيجي
الشامل وهذا هو الوضع الذي يحدد ما يجب ان
يكون بين بلدينا من علاقات وثيقه
كثيره للملفات على جدول مباحثات الرئيسين
بما فيها تلك التي تشغل العالم مؤخرا بسبب
الحرب في اوكرانيا
على اقتراحاتكم بشان تسويه الازمه الحاده
في اوكرانيا وبالطبع ستكون لدينا
الامكانيه لبحث المساله ندرك تماما انكم
تنطلقون من مبدا العداله واحترام اسس
القانون الدولي ومبادئه وانتم تعلمون اننا
دائما منفتحون على عمليه التفاوض سنناقشه
كافه هذه المسائل ومقترحاتكم والتي
نحترمها باهتمام كبير تتعامل موسكو مع هذه
الزياره
فنتائجها يمكن ان تجلب حلولا اقتصاديه
لروسيا تخفف عنها عبء العقوبات الغربيه
يتركز الاهتمام على الاستثمارات في قطاع
الطاقه والصناعه والخدمات اللوجستيه اضافه
الى ما يمكن ان تخرج به القمه من اتفاقيات
في المجال العسكري التقني لا سيما محاجه
البلدين الى التقنيات العسكريه المتبادله
في ضوء ازدياد حده التوتر قرب حدودهما
القمه تاتي على خلفيه تصعيد في اللهجه من
قبل موسكو اللتين ترفضان الهيمنه الغربيه
في العالم واستمرار الحرب في اوكرانيا اما
مبادره السلام الصينيه فحظوظها في النجاح
معدومه لان الغرب لا يريد عمليه سلام كتب
عليها صنعت في الصين والايجابي فيها ان
الصين خرجت بفضلها من خندقها لتقدم نفسها
ايضا قوه دبلوماسيه دوليه
على المستوى
لم
يخفن في تصريحات استبقت القمه رغبتهما في
رؤيه عالم اكثر تكافؤا متعدد الاقطاب لا
يتجزا فيه الامن تحكمه الشرعيه دوليه وليس
هيمنه غربيه
تتوجه نافسي روسيا والصين الى مخرجات
القمه يوم الثلاثاء لاسيما ما يتعلق منها
باوكرانيا وبافاق التحالف الروسي الصيني
الذي لا حدود له كما يؤكد بوتين
الجزيره موسكو
مدير مجلس الامن القومي الامريكيه السابق
لشؤون الصين والنبجين فيكتور نائب رئيس
مركز الصين والعولمه
نبدا معك سيد والدر
لماذا تستبق واشنطن نتائج زياره
وتعتبرها بانها نوع من الخداع خصوصا ما
يتعلق بخطه السلام الصينيه في اوكرانيا
المتحده قد
تمعنت في خطه السلام الصينيه ذات عشره
نقطه ووجدت ان هناك احتمال
للتواصل الى وقف
اطلاق النار بين الطرفين لكن
اوعى بقاء الامور على حالها هذا يعني من
وجهه نظر اوكرانيا ان توتن سيحتفظ لنفسه
بعشرين في المئه من الاراضي اوكرانيا وهذا
امر غير مقبول
سيد قال
ما الذي غير اتفاقات التعاون
والتعاون الاستراتيجي والاقتصادي وغير ذلك
ما الذي ستقدمه الصين لموسكو في هذه
الزياره
[موسيقى]
الرئيس
هي زياره مهمه للغايه من حيث تعزيز
الصداقه والتعاون بين روسيا والصين من جهه
لكن ما هو اكثر اهميه ربما هو ان الرئيس
سيبحث مع الرئيس بوتين والحكومه الروسيه
مقترح السلام الروسي الدكتور والد التحدث
عن وقف اطلاق النار مقابل فقدان اراضي هذا
تشويش وخلط بين فكرتين مختلفتين تماما وقف
اطلاق النار لا يعني بالضروره الاعتراف
بوضعيه الاراضي التي تحت السيطره اي من
الطرفين لان وقف اطلاق النار هو الشرط
المسبق للنقاش والتفاوض في النهايه
النزاع على الاراضي
والاقاليم بين البلدين سيتم
بالوسائل السلميه لهذا السبب ان نسمي وقف
اطلاق النار اعترافا بسيطره طرف على اخر
من حيث الاراضي والاحتلال هو سوء تصوير
للمبادره الصينيه
وتجاهل فاضح لحقائق الامور وقف اطلاق
النار لا يعني ترسيم الحدود النهائيه بين
الطرفين سيد وادلر طب اذا اذا كان الموقف
الامريكي
يعتبر بان هذه الخطه نوع من الخداع ولا
يعلق امالا على هذه الزياره لشي الى موسكو
لماذا اذا طلبت واشنطن من الرئيس الصيني
ان يكون على اتصال بيزنسكي الرئيس
الاوكراني يعني ما فائده الاتصال اذا
دعما كبيرا واستراتيجيا ووقوفا خلف الرئيس
بوتين حتى فيما يتعلق بالحرب على اوكرانيا
بقدر تعلق الامر بالحرب موقف الصين ومنذ
البدايه ومنذ الرابع والعشرين من شهر 2022
كان موقفا واضحا الصين تعارض الحرب
وتحثر كلا من روسيا واوكرانيا على وقف
القتال والدخول في مفاوضات من دون او مع
وساطه الصين اي طرف قادر وراغب في التوسط
يجب ان يفعل ذلك بين روسيا واوكرانيا لكي
توقف الحرب ان يؤدي ذلك الى استئناف في
حاله السلام موقف الصين لم يكن ابدا بنفس
الوضوح الذي هو عليه الان هناك بلدان لا
تريد وقف الحرب هل تريد الحث على
استمرارها واطاله اعمدها لهذا السبب تستمر
في ارسال السلاح الاوكراني ارسال السلاح
الاوكرانيا لن يغير من طبيعه المعارك على
الارض لان كلما زادت كميات الاسلحه
المرسله كلما زاد عدد المدنيين القتلى
وسيكون ذلك كارثه على الناس اوكرانيا اذا
انا الاوان نوقف الحرب والنسبح
للدبلوماسيه
والمفاوضات ان تاخذ دورها لحل النزاعات
ايا كان الطبيعتها بين اوكرانيا وروسيا
الحلب هو الامر الوحيد ودعوني اؤكد ايضا
كانت دائما هناك قنوات اتصال بين الصين
واوكرانيا على اعلى المستويات
فاوكرانيا كانت لها دور مهم في راي الصين
وعلى العالم ان يعرف ان قبل الحرب الصين
كانت اكبر مستثمر في اوكرانيا
دمرت
الى
سؤال له له علاقه بدور الولايات المتحده
العالمي يبدو وكان الولايات المتحده سيد
وادلر
تخشى فعلا من بروز
هذه الاقطاب الكبرى لتنافس الولايات
المتحده على قياده العالم يعني اذا اجتمعت
روسيا والصين ستكون هناك قوه موازيه فعلا
على كل المستويات
لمزاحمه ومنافسه الولايات المتحده وهذا ما
تخشاه واشنطن ما ردك على ذلك باختصار
ان هذا ما تخاف منه واشنطن على الاطلاق ما
تقلقوا بشانه واشنطن بان الدكتور جاوي
يقول انه في الصين كان محايدا في واقع
الحال الصين لم تدن روسيا ابدا لغزوها
لاوكرانيا ولم تدن روسيا على الاباده التي
قامت بها في اوكرانيا والان المحكمه
الجنائيه
[موسيقى]
الدوليه
خرجت في موقف ضد بوتين اذا على الصين ان
تحسم امرها اذا ارادت ان تكون وسيطا نزيها
بين روسيا واوكرانيا شكرا للدينس مدير
مجلس الامن القومي الامريكيه السابق لشؤون
الصين وشكرا لفيكتور جو نائب رئيس مركز
الصين والعولمه كان معنا من بيجين
اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه ان الدفاع
الجوي الروسي رصد يوم 20 مارس قاذفتين
استراتيجيتين امريكيتين من طراز بي 52
تحلقان باتجاه الحدود الروسيه فوق بحر
البلطيق وقالت الوزاره في بيان ان مقاتله
روسيه من طراز سوخوي 35 اقلعت الاعتراض
القذيفتين اللتين لم تنتهك الحدود الروسيه
وعدت الى قاعدتها بعد ابتعاد القذفتين
الامريكيتين حسب وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
لمزيد من التفاصيل ينضم الينا من موسكو
مدير مكتب الجزيره زاور شاوج زاور في اي
سياق تضع روسيا هذا التحرك العسكري الجوي
الاعتراض
المقاتلتين الامريكيتين
نعم حسنا تضعه في سياق
[موسيقى]
رار بامن روسيا من قبل قوات حلف شمال
الاطلسي بدا قبل حتى العمليه العسكريه
الروسيه في اوكرانيا ربما اعاده هذه
الاعتراضات تتكرر في الاونه الاخيره حسن
والتي كنا نشهدها منذ عام 2018
بشكل كبير في فوق البحر البلطيق وفوق
البحر الاسود اضافه الى منطقه المحيط
الهادف باقصى الشبكه الروسي ربما هذا
التحليق التحليق
لطائرتين استراتيجيتين امريكيتين من طراز
ب 52 هي
واضحه انه يشكل تهديدا للامن الروسي خاصه
وانا من طراز هذه الطائرات حلقت في
الاسبوع الماضي في ثلاث
طلعات فوق دول البلطيق استونيلات
والاسوانيا بالقرب من الحدود الروسيه اذا
كنا نعلم انها تبعد يعني تبعد هذه الدول
فعليا تقع على حدود روسيا المسافه ليست
العاصمه الروسيه او موسكو وبالتالي ايضا
ربما اهميه هذه هذا الحادث اليوم هو
اعتراض ربما لم يؤدي الى مواجهه انه ياتي
بعد ايام قليله من ازمه كبيره اندلعت بين
روسيا والولايات المتحده الامريكيه على
خلفيه سقوط او اسقاط
للمسيره الامريكيه فوق البحر الاسود شكرا
جزيلا لك زور شاوج مدير مكتب الجزيره في
موسكو
[موسيقى]
اقر الاتحاد الاوروبي تخصيصا ملياري يورو
لدعم اوكرانيا عسكريا كما اعلن وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه انطوني بلينكن في بيان
عن مساعده عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه
350 مليون دولار بينما اعلن رئيس فاجنر
سيطرت مقاتليه على نحو 70% من ضخمه
نداءات الرئيس الاوكراني الاخيره الى
الحلفاء باستعجال مد بلاده بالذخيره
المشكه على النفاذ سرعان ما لاقت استجابه
واسعه على ضفتي الاطلسي
خارجيه دول الاتحاد الاوروبي على خطه
بقيمه مليار اليورو لتزويد اوكرانيا
بالذخائر حيث ستتسلم في دفعه اولى نحو
مليون قذيفه بحلول نهايه ايار مايو المقبل
كما اوصى الاجتماع بزياده قدرات انتاج
شركات التسليح الاوروبيه من اجل تجديد
مخزونات دول الاتحاد
ومواصله امداد القوات الاوكرانيه
وتبدو تلك القرارات متسقه مع تقديرات
اوروبيه قائله بان الحرب تدخل مرحله خطيره
وان احتياجاتك في ازدياد لاسيما في ضوء
حشد الروس اكثر من ثلاثمائه الف مقاتل لشن
هجوم واسع قد يكون وشيكا
في نفس اليوم وبفارق ساعات اعلن وزير
الخارجيه الامريكيه توني بلينكن تقديم
مساعدات عسكريه جديده لاوكرانيا بقيمه 350
مليون دولار وبحسب بيان بلينكن ستتضمن
حزمه المساعدات الجديده صواريخ هارم
ومدافع هي مارز
وذخائر مختلفه
ميدانيا تحتدم اكثر معركه باخموت في شرق
اوكرانيا ويتبادل المتحاربان القصف
والاتهامات مع تعهد كل منهما بحسم المعركه
لصالحه في النهايه
مالك شركه فاجنر العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه
التي تقود الهجوم على مدينه بخموت اعلن ان
مقاتليه بات يسيطرون على 70% من المدينه
لكنه لم يبدو واثقا من الحفاظ على تلك
المكاسب اذ كرر مخاوفه السابقه من ان
القوات الاو تخطط لهجوم واسع اوائل ابر
للمقبل لقطع التواصل بين قواته ووحدات
الجيش الروسي
وناشد بريجوجين وزير الدفاع الروسي اتخاذ
كافه الاجراءات الضروريه للحيلوله دون
حدوث ذلك لان يتاثر سير العمليه العسكريه
وفق قوله تصريحات قائد ميليشيا فاجنر تبدو
استمرارا لخلافاته المعلنه مع القياده
العسكريه الروسيه في جبهه بخموت التي
اصبحت رمزا للنزاع بين الروس والاوكرانيين
بسبب طول امد المعركه والخسائر الفادحه
التي تكبدها الجانبان
[موسيقى]
استدعت الخارجيه الاردنيه سفيره اسرائيل
في عمان بعد تصريحات لوزير الماليه
الاسرائيلي بيتسلس مودريتش وصفتها الوزاره
بالتحريضيه واستخدامه خريطه لاسرائيل تضم
الاردن والاراضي الفلسطينيه وقال رئيس
المكتب السياسي لحركه حماس اسماعيل هنيه
ان تصريحات الوزير الاسرائيلي تستوجب
اداره حوار استراتيجي مع الاردن لمواجهه
هذه التوجهات الخطيره حسب تعبيره واعتبر
هنيه ان تصريحات موتريتش تجاه الاردن تكشف
العقيده السياسيه للكيان الاسرائيلي من
جهتها اعلنت الخارجيه الاسرائيليه
التزامها باتفاقيه السلام مع الاردن
واعترافها بوحده اراضي المملكه
هذا ودان رئيس الوزراء الفلسطيني محمد
شتيا تصريحات وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
واكد في مستهل جلسه الحكومه الفلسطينيه
الاسبوعيه ان تلك التصريحات دليل قاطع على
الفكر العنصري المتطرف الذي يحكم اطراف
الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه حسب وصفه
ان التصريحات التي ادلى بها الوزير
الاسرائيلي اسمه لا يوجد شعب فلسطيني وانه
تم اختراعه في اخر مئه عام دليل قاطع على
الفكر الصهيوني العنصر المتطرف الذي يحكم
اطراف الحكومه الاسرائيليه الحاليه ان هذه
التصريحات التحريضيه منسجمه مع المقولات
الصهيونيه الاولى ارض بلا شعب لشعب بلا
ارض وان الاراضي الفلسطينيه متنازع عليها
وانها ارض الميعاد وهكذا من ادعاءات وهي
وهميه
وصف فرحان حق نائب المتحدث باسم الامين
العام للامم المتحده تصريحات وزير الماليه
الاسرائيليه
بشان عدم وجود شعب فلسطيني بانها تصريحات
غير مفيده على الاطلاق وقال حق ان المنظمه
الدوليه تدعم حقوق الشعب الفلسطيني
هذا النوع من التصريحاته غير مفيد على
الاطلاق من الواضح ان هناك شعبا فلسطينيين
وتؤيد الامم المتحده حقوقه هناك قرارات
لمجلس الامن والجمعيه العامه تشير الى
الفلسطينيين ونحن نواصل دعم حقوقهم
والضغطه من اجل حل الدولتين الذي سينتج
عنه دولتان اسرائيل وفلسطين تعيشان جنبا
الى جنب في سلام وامن
وقال مفوض السياسات الخارجيه الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيفوريل ان تصريحات وزير
الماليه الاسرائيليه
غير مقبوله ومرفوضه تماما وانها تزيد من
التوتر في المنطقه مضيفا ان الاتحاد
الاوروبي سيظل ملتزما بحل الدولتين
[موسيقى]
تعليقات الوزير سموتريتش تذهب مره اخرى في
الاتجاه المعاكس وبالتاكيد لا يمكن
التسامح معها وادعو الحكومه الاسرائيليه
نفسها الى رفضها هذه التعليقات مرفوضه من
الوزير انه خطا انه عدم احترام انه امر
خطير من غير المجدي قول هذا النوع من
الاشياء في موقف متوتر بالفعل سنواصل
التزامنا الطويل الامد بحل الدولتين مع
اقامه دوله فلسطينيه مستقله ذات السياده
تعيش جنبا الى جنب مع اسرائيل في سلام
وامن هل يمكنك ان تتخيل كيف سيكون الرد لو
قال الرئيس الفلسطيني الشيء نفسه
وفي احداث المواقف الفلسطينيه الخارجيه
الفلسطينيه استهجنت سماح السلطات الفرنسيه
باطلاق تصريحاته العنصريه والفاشيه من على
اراضيها
ينضم الينا من عمان مراسله الجزيره تامر
الصمادي تامر اضافه الى استدعاء السفير
الاسرائيلي في عمان كيف بدا عليه الموقف
الاردني ايضا من تصريحات
بالفعل للموقف الاردني حسن يتصاعد على
الارجح بشكل تدريجي هذا ما اشار اليه عدد
من المصادر الاردنيين للجزيره واحد اولئك
المصادر قال بان خطوات اخرى قد تتخذ خلال
الساعات المقبله منها على الارجح ربما
استدعاء السفير الاردني من تل ابيب لغايات
التشاور وقبل ذلك بالفعل كانت وزاره
الخارجيه تستدعي السفير الاسرائيلي في
عمان وتحمله رساله شديده اللهجه علمنا بان
الاردن خلال هذا الاستدعاء طلب من السفير
الاسرائيلي ان يطلب من حكومته ضروره تبيان
الموقف الاسرائيلي الرسمي بشكل واضح مما
اعلنه الرئيس او وزير عفوا الماليه
الاسرائيلي وايضا استخدامه لخارطه
لاسرائيل خارطه لاسرائيل فيها الاردنيه
بالاضافه الى الاراضي الفلسطينيه المحتله
الموقف الاردني كما قلت وانقل هنا عن
مصادر اردنيه رسميه يتصاعد شيئا فشيئا وهو
في اطار الدبلوماسيه الاردنيه الذي تقوده
وزاره الخارجيه
الاردنيه والادانات ايضا تتصاعد كما قلت
رسميا وشعبيا قبل قليل كانت هنالك ادانا
واضحه من قبل البرلمان الاردني بشقيها
النواب والاعيان رئيس مجلس النواب طالب
الحكومه باتخاذ خطوات يعني وصفها بضروره
ان تكون خطوات قويه للرد على هذا الاعتداء
كما وصفه وايضا هنالك عدد من النواب في
مجلس النواب طالبوا الحكومه بضروره طرد
السفيره الاسرائيلي من عمان وسحب السفير
الاردني من تل ابيب ايضا
الاعيان مجلس الاعيان مجلس الملك كانت
هنالك له ادانه واضحه ووصف الخطوه التي
اقدم عليها وزير الماليه الاسرائيلي
بدنيئه والخطيره وفي الحقيقه هذه
الاستفزازات هي استفزازات متجدده ومتواصله
لسيما بعد احتضان نعم عذرا انتهى الوقت
تامر صمادي شكرا جزيلا لك مراسل الجزيره
من عمان
[موسيقى]
قلم مفوض العلاقات الخارجيه في الاتحاد
الاوروبي جوزيف بوريل ان تونس تواجه وضعا
يترافق فيه عدم الاستقرار السياسي مع وضع
اقتصادي لا يمكن ان يؤدي الى اتفاق مع
صندوق النقد الدولي اما في تونس فقد نظم
انصار الرئيس التونسي مظاهره مددوا فيها
بما يعتبرونه تدخلات اجنبيه في شؤون
بلادهم
انصار الرئيس التونسي قيس سعيد في الشارع
للتعبير عن دعمهم لاجراءاته وخطواته هنا
تردد نفس شعارات الرئيس محاسبه الفاسدين
والخونه ورفض التدخل الاجنبي لانه اعتداء
على سياده تونس النابعه من اراده الشعب
لكن هذه الشعارات لن تمنع الجهات الاجنبيه
المختلفه من الحديث عن الوضع في تونس كما
هو الشان هنا في الاتحاد الاوروبي هذه
المره تضاف الى النقاش الازمه التي نجمت
عن تصريحات الرئيس التونسي الاخير بشان
المهاجرين من افريقيا جنوب الصحراء
انه وضع اقتصادي وسياسي مؤلم تواجه تونس
وضعا يترافق فيه عدم الاستقرار السياسي مع
وضع اقتصادي مزر لا يمكن ان يؤدي الى
اتفاق مع صندوق النقد الدولي بالاضافه الى
ذلك فهنالك تصريحات غير المقبوله بشان
المهاجرين من جنوب الصحراء الكبرى يشير
هنا الى مفاوضات تونس مع صندوق النقد
الدولي للحصول على قرض بقيمه مليار
وتسعمائه مليون دولار كانت متعطره فنقلتها
تصريحات سعيد بشان المهاجرين الى وضع اسوا
تحاول ايطاليا المتخوفه من تدفق موجه طالب
اللجوء على شواطئها قادمين من تونس اقناع
حلفائها الغربيين بتسهيل حصول تونس على
القرض لكن جهودها تصطدم بمواقف عده دول
تريد ان ترى اصلاحات في تونس الولايات
المتحده طالبت بهذا الاصلاحات عده مرات في
اخر تصريحات الامريكيه قال وزير الخارجيه
ان الولايات المتحده ستواصل دعم التطلعات
الشعب التونسي الى مستقبل ديمقراطي مزدهر
ودعم الجهود القائمه لحمايه حقوق الانسان
وسياده القانون قبل ذلك وبعد الانتخابات
الاخيره ونسبه المشاركه المتدنيه اكدت
واشنطن اهميه تبني اصلاحات شامله وشفافه
بما في ذلك تمكن هيئه تشريعيه المنتخبه
وانشاء المحكمه الدستوريه وحمايه حقوق
الانسان
وبعد حمله الاعتقالات في صفوف معارض سعيد
عبر المتحدث باسم الخارج الامريكيه عن قلق
الولايات المتحده الشديد ازاء تقارير عن
اعتقال شخصيات سياسيه ورجال اعمال
وصحافيين في تونس رد الرئيس التونسي على
الانتقادات الغربيه وقال ان تونس دوله
مستقله ذات السياده وليس تحت الاستعمار
وانه يعلم جيدا ما يقوم به في ظل احترام
القانون تحاول الدول الغربيه ابقاء قنوات
الاتصال مفتوحه مع السلطه في تونس وتبدي
فرنسا وايطاليا مرونه في التعامل معها لكن
دولا غربيه اخرى على راسها الولايات
المتحده لا تخفي امتعاضها من اسلوب الرئيس
سعيد في التعامل مع شؤون البلاد
ينظم الى
[موسيقى]
عضو لجنه الخارجيه في البرلمان
الاوروبيه سيد فابيو ما هي الماخذ
الاوروبيه والغربيه عموما على تونس اليوم
والتي ستمنعها كما
يبدو من كلام جوزيف بوريل من ان تنجح
مفاوضاتها مع صندوق النقد الدولي
السلام عليكم
اود ان اقول انني دائما كنت مقربا من
الشعب التونسي وكنت كبير مراقبين الاتحاد
الاوروبي
ومقرر خاص بالنسبه الى البرلمان الاوروبي
تونس دوله بحاجه الى دعمنا ونحن
نتفهم هذه المرحله الصعبه الاجتماعيه
والاقتصاديه التي تمر بها البلاد ليس فقط
نتيجه الحرب في اوكرانيا وليس فقط
بسبب فتره ما بعد رائحه كورونا ولكن
ايضا بسبب الحرب الاهليه في ليبيا
المجاوره بالرغم من ذلك نحن قلقون من
التطورات التي حصلت في اخر سنتين حيث قرر
الرئيس عيد ان يقود المصادر الديمقراطيه
في البلاد وان يستاثر بالسلطه في يده وان
يحكم لفتره طويله بموجب مرسومها بصوره
عامه هذا ليس جانبا يمكننا ان نعرب عن
وفقنا عليها او ولا موجات التوقيفات
الاعتقالات عفوا عفوا سيد فابيو
مؤيدون رئيس يتحدثون
بصراحه عن ان الرئيس
لبى مطالب الشعب وانه عمل استشاره شعبيه
كانت الكترونيه ثم استفتاء على دستور جديد
ثم انتخابات تشريعيه ولو بنسبه احد عشر
بالمئه من مجمل الناخبين لكن يقول
المؤيدون ان هذه اراده الشعب التونسي ما
رايك
في الحقيقه حين يكون معدل التصويت بهذا
الانخفاض لا يمكن ان نعتبر ان هذا العمليه
الصوفي المعايير الدوليه
ولا يتم اذا ارسال بعثت مراقبه اعتقد ان
تونس يجب ان تعطي الفرصه لكافه الاحزاب
ولكافه الاطراف من اجل اصلاح البلاد
ولتخطي الصعوبات التي تمنع توصل اتفاق مع
صندوق النفط الدولي علما هذا الاتفاق
اساسي لضمان استقرار البلاد
وللاستمرار في تقديم الاجوبه او على الاقل
السفاء مطالب الناس ايضا مكافحه الفساد
امر اساسي ولكن يجب ان يحصل مع احترامي
دوله القانون وحقوق الانسان وليس توقيف
الناس عشوائيا توقيف توقيف الناس عشوائيا
يعني هذه هذه النقطه اشرت اليها الاجابه
الاولى والان كيف تنظر الى هذه التوقيفات
التي
تتم تحت او بتهمه التامر على امن الدوله
في تونس هي توقيفات ضد المعارضين لقيس
سعيد ولكن
التهمه قضائيه وهي التامر على امن الدوله
اتهامات خطيره جدا يجب ان نرى كيف ستقام
هذه المحاكمات
اذا سوف يسمح لي المتهمين بالدفاع عن
انفسهم
لانه يمكن فعلا ان اتحدث عن خلط للسلطات
وعدم احترام السلطه القضائيه واستقلاليات
هذا امر يجب ان اتنبه له مره اخرى اكرر
نحن نتفهم هذه الصعوبات التي يمر بها
الشعب التونسي ولكن هذا لا يمكنه طبعا ان
يبرر
موضوع
المعارك
القضائيه وغيرها التي حصلت بعد الثوره هذا
امر مهم جدا بالنسبه الينا كاروبيين
فاليوماسيمك ستالدو عضو لجنه الخارجيه في
البرلمان الاوروبي شكرا جزيلا لك
ونبقى في نفس الموضوع من تونس مع احمد
الهمامي المتحدث باسم تحالف احرار مرحبا
بك السيد الهمامي يعني كما هو واضح من
التصريحات الغربيه والامريكيه وغيرها ان
الرئيس قيس سعيد رغم كل
ما قام به لم يستطع ان يقنع الجهات
الدوليه بان ما يقوم به هو اراده الشعب
التونسي وان الديمقراطيه او حريه التعبير
مصامه في تونس ما رايك
شكرا لكم مساء النور لك ولجميع متابعي
قناه الجزيره دعنا نقول يعني ان الرئيس
قيس سعيد يعني توجه نحو الشعب والشعب هو
الذي انتخب ذلك الدستور وصوت على ذلك
الدستور
بما يعادل ذلك البرلمان الذريه لكن ما
نستغربه من الاتحاد الاوروبي ليس من صالح
الاتحاد الاوروبي تضعف تونس ماديا او ليس
من صالح صندوق نقل الدولي ان تضعف تضعف
تونس ميلاديه فهذا ليس من صالح اوروبا
خصيصا لانه تعرف هناك تدعيه جيو
استراتيجيه
وجود سياسيه تكون خطيره بالحد الادنى لحد
الادنى نقول عليه خطيره بالنسبه لاوروبا
اكثر من دول اخرى
جنوب اوروبا مثل ايطاليا
وفرنسا وسمعنا تصريحات لوزيره الخارجيه
وزير الخارجيه الايطالي اليوم هو يقول عن
تونس من الماديه بما كانت في الكفايه لكن
الرئيس قيس سعيد
الان لا زلنا في حاله الاستثناء ستنتهي
قريبا بعد هذا البرنامج في في هذا
البرنامج وهو كان نفذ كل الوعود وكل
الطريقه التي وضعها ابتداء من يعني 25
جويليه ولغايه الاستفتاء الاستشاره ثم
الاستفتاء لكن يبقى سؤالي يبقى سؤالي نفسه
لم يستطع ان يقنع احدا بذلك يعني هناك من
ايده في الداخل لكن هناك ايضا معارضه
واسعه من كل الاطياف له وخارجيا يعني يبدو
الرئيس قيس سعيد وكانه معزول اكان افريقيا
او حتى غربيا او اطراف اقليميه ودوليه
وبالتالي يعني كيف له ان يطلب مساعده او
ان يطلب تاييدا وهو غير مقنع لاحد من
اولئك
شكرا لك مره اخرى سؤالك واضح وكنت اجيب لك
على سؤالك ليست في عزله لا دوليه واكبر
من ايامات قليله اجتماع مجلس الوزراء
الداخليه العرب وكان ذلك الاجتماع في تونس
والذكر ثمانيه في جربه
واحمد الهمامي عضو تحالف احرار
تونس شكرا جزيلا لك عذرا انقطع التواصل
[موسيقى]
اعلنا المبعوث الامامي الى اليمن هانس
جروندمبر اتفاق الاطراف اليمنيه على اطلاق
سراحه 887 اسيرا وذلك خلال المحادثات
الجاريه بسويسرا ووصف المبعوثه لاتفاق
بالخطوه الايجابيه مطالبا بتفعيله في اقرب
وقت واعلنا ان الاطراف اليمنيه ستلتقي
مجددا فيما يغير المقبل من جهتها اعتبرت
اللجنه الدوليه للصليب الاحمر ان اتفاق
تبادل الاسرى سينهي معاناه عائلات مشتته
ويساعد على بناء الثقه معربه عن عملها في
التواصل الى اتفاقات اخرى لتبادل الاسرى
وكان رئيس وفد جماعه انصار الله الحوثيين
لمفاوضات تبادل الاسرى باليمن عبد القادر
المرتضى قد قال انه جرى الاتفاق في سويسرا
على صفقه تبادل واسعه تشمل
706 اسرع من الحوثيين في مقابل
181 اسيرا من الطرف الحكومي بينهم سعوديون
وسودانيون واضاف المرتضى في تغريده ان
الصفقه ستنفذ بعد ثلاثه اسابيع كما ستعقد
جوله اخرى بعد شهر رمضان المبارك لاستكمال
تنفيذ بقيه الاتفاق
من جانب اقل عضو الوزن الحكوميه ماجد
فضائل ان الصفقه ستشمل
880 اسيرا ومختطفا في مرحله اولى تتبعها
مراحل اخرى وصولا الى الافراج عن كل
الاسرى على اساس قاعده الكل مقابل الكل
واضاف في تغريده على تويتر ان الصفقه تشمل
اربعه صحفيين محكوم عليهم بالاعدام وقضى
عسكريين ومدنيين وعددا من اسرى التحالف
[موسيقى]
رفض نواب الجمعيه الوطنيه الفرنسيه
مذكرتين لحجب الثقه عن حكومته اليزابيث
هما المعارضه وكان البرلمان صوت على
المذكرتين اثر تفعيل الحكومه مقتضيات
دستوريه لتمرير قانون اصلاح نظام التقاعد
دون اخضاعه لتصديق البرلمان
وبموازاه هذا الحراك البرلماني تستمر
الاحتجاجات العنيفه في الشارع رفضا لتعديل
قانون التقاعد
واخد شهدت عده مدن فرنسيه تجمعات احتجاجيه
بعد فشل البرلمان في التصويت لصالح سحب
الثقه من الحكومه وطلب المحتجون الذين
خرجوا في مدن باريس وران وتولوز
باستقاله الرئيس الفرنسي
وقد تدخلت قوه مكافحه الشغب لفتح الطرقات
بعد اغلاقها بالقمامه من قبل المحتجين في
احياء بالعاصمه الفرنسيه
تنضموا الينا من باريس الدكتوره فيرجيني
مارتن استاذه
مارتن مرحبا بك ماذا بعد نجاه حكومه
اليزابيث بورن من اختبار
حجم الثقه في الجمعيات الوطنيه
[موسيقى]
من الصعب احتوائها هناك نوع من
الراديكاليه
وتطرف في فرنسا منذ ان مر هذا القانون يوم
الخميس الماضي بدون التصويت عليه وبالتالي
ساد التوتر وبالتالي كان هناك
ترقب من قبل معظم الفرنسيين في مشروع حاجب
الثقه هذا الذي سقط طبخه سوني بابا بعد ان
لم يمر بسبب تسعه اصوات كانت تنقص
المعارضه الان
اصبح مشروع اصلاح نظام التقاعد امرا واقعا
صحيح يعني لم يعد امامه اي معوقات
لا يزال هناك معوقات محتمله لانه هناك
لجوء للمجلس الدستوري للتاكد من دستوريه
هذا المشروع
وصحتي هذا من جهه من جهه اخرى هناك ايضا
احتمال لما نسميه استفتاء من خلال مبادره
مشتركه والذي من شانه ان يحشد الكثير من
الناس والذي من شانه ان يعيد هذا النص اي
اما الى البرلمان او لعرضه على الاستفتاء
الشعبي طيب هناك معلومات تظهر على الشاشه
وسائل الاعلام فرنسيه تتحدث عن ان الشرطه
اعتقلت العشرات خلال احتجاجات عنيفه في
باريس على تمرير هذا القانون هل هذه
الاعتقالات ستكون او يعني استخدام هذا
السلاح سيكون هو المسيطر عند الشرطه في
المرحله القادمه بعد نجاه الحكومه من
تصويت سحب الثقه
صحيح ان هذا الوضع متوتر في الميدان لقد
شهدنا ذلك في فرنسا قبل مرحله
الجائحه مع السطر الصفراء كان هناك مواجهه
احيانا كانت عنيفه مع الشرطه والان مره
اخرى يمكننا ان نسترجع هذه الذكريات نرى
نفس المشاهد وجود الشرطه مكافحه الشغب
ومتظاهرين وهناك تطرف في السلوك من
الطرفين
فرجيني مارتن استاذه العلوم السياسيه كنت
معنا من باريس شكرا جزيلا لك
[موسيقى]
اثار مسلسل بنك كريدي سويس العريق الذي
انتهت ازمته بعمليه ادماجه مع البنك
المنافس
[موسيقى]
اثار رد فعل عالميا لم يحدث منذ جائحه
كورونا في ذروتها اذا اعلن مجلس الاحتياطي
الفيدرالي انضمامه الى البنوك المركزيه في
كندا وانجلترا واليابان والاتحاد الاوروبي
وسويسرا في اجراء منسق لتعزيز السيوله في
السوق وتعهد البنك المركزي الاوروبي
بتقديم قروض لدعم بنوك منطقه اليورو اذا
لزم الامر قائلا ان انقاذ السويس ضروري
لاستعاده الهدوء في السوق المصرفي وكريدي
سويس هو اكبر البنوك تاثرا باضطرابات
الاسواق العالميه التي نجمت عن النياري
بنكاي سيليكون فالي وسجنتشر في الولايات
المتحده ولا يزال القطاع المصرفي
والامريكي يعاني مشكلات فقد استمرت الضغوط
على اسهم البنوك بالرغم من تحرك عده بنوك
كبرى لا يداع 30 مليار دولار في بنك فرست
ببابلك الذي تاثر جراء انهيار بنكي
سيليكون فالي وسجنتشر
وكانت السلطات السويسريه قد اعلنت تخصيص
نحو
260 مليار فرانك سويسري اي مئتين مليار
دولار لانقاذ بنك سويس بعد موافقه يو بي
اس على شراء منافسه
المبلغ المذكور هو ثلث الناتج المحليه
الاجماليه للبلاد لحمايه سويسرا من
الاضطرابات الماليه العالميه وقال بنك يو
بي اس انه سيدفع ثلاثه مليارات و200 مليون
دولار للاستحواذ على كريدي سويس الذي تاسس
قبل
167 عاما بينما قالت الحكومه ان يو بي اس
سيتحمل ايضا خسائر اوليه بقيمه خمسه
مليارات و400 مليون دولار بسبب تصفيه
تعاقدات ماليه واصول اخرى محفوفه بالمخاطر
تتضمن صفقه تقديم دعم مالي كبير وتعهدا من
الحكومه السويسريه لتحمل نحو تسعه مليارات
فرنك من الخسائر المحتمله جراء عمليه
الاستحواذ وقد عرض البنك المركزي السويسري
على البنكين بعد اندماجها بعد اندماجيهما
قرضا بنحو 100 مليار السويسريه ضمن حزمه
توفير السيوله في حالات الطوارئ وكان
كريدي سويس ويوبيس ضمن مجموعه مكونه من 30
بنكا عالميا مهما تراقبها الجهات
التنظيميه عنك
تنضم الينا من لندن فيكي برايس كبيره
المستشارين الاقتصاديين في مركز ابحاث
الاقتصاد والاعمال
البريطانيه سيده فيكي مرحبا بك
يعني عمليات الاستحواذ هذه على البنوك
التي تواجه مصاعب كريد سويس
حتى الان لم تؤثر ايجابا على
الاسهم والاسواق العالميه وحتى يعني بدل
ان تطمئن تزيد المخاوف على بنوك اخرى
لماذا
حيث
حاجه للمزيد من الدعم
للبنوك والناس ما زالوا يسحبون ودائعهم
اذا هناك
الصوت يتقطع من المصدر
حيث اجزاء من القطاع المالي
صعوبه وكذلك
عملائهم هناك مشكله اكبر يجب ان ينتبه
اليها ليس فقط ما يحصل للبنوك الكبرى ولكن
هل نحن حقيقه اضعفنا النظام المالي برمته
في العامين الماضيين بسبب الاداره الماليه
ساكون اكثر شفافيه ووضوحا هل نحن امام
ازمه
مصرفيه عالميه
وبالتالي امام ازمه ماليه عالميه نتيجه
احجار الدومينو المتمثله بالبنوك
[موسيقى]
التي تواجه مصاعد
انما سنراه
بالشكل
شبه مؤكد هو سيكون هناك المزيد من الحذر
فيما يتعلق
بالقراض وربما هناك توقعات
تشير الى تباطؤ في معدلات النمو في اوروبا
اذا ربما ليس ازمه ماليه كامله وشامله لكن
بالتاكيد الكثير من القلق حول التنظيمات
الماليه موجوده بشكل فعال وهل ستبقى
البنوك تقرض بعضها البعض وتثقوا ببعضها
البعض
خاصه تتعلق باقراض الشركات الناشئه وشركات
التقنيات العاليه
طبعا هذه التداعيات قد لا تصل الى درجه
مفعول لعبه الدومينو وتساقط احجارها لكن
سيكون هناك نظره اكثر حذرا الى الكيفيه
التي ينظم بها هذا القطاع وهل ان السياس
يتقطع من المصدر
ربما سوف نرى
المزيد من
الرسمله وسيوله من جانب الحكومات
للضمان ان البنوك ستستمر في الاقراض والا
سيتراجع الاقرار في وقت الاقتصاد العالمي
بمس الحاجه الى اعاده النمو بعد جائحه
وقتنا لكن يبقى السؤال عمن يدفع هذه
الاموال والى اي مدى يعني دافع الضرائب
ومن يتحمل
المسؤوليه في نهايه المطاف فيك برايس من
لندن كبيره المستشارين الاقتصاديين في
مركز ابحاث الاقتصاد والاعمال البريطانيه
والمستشاره الاقتصاديه السابقه لدى
الحكومه البريطانيه اشكرك جزيلا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
مشاهدينا من جديد الى افريقيا ومتاعبها قد
يؤدي الجفاف القياسيه الذي يشهده القرن
الافريقي الى
135 وفاه يوميا في الصومال خلال الاشهر
السته الاولى من العام الحديث التحذير جاء
في دراسه اصدرتها اليوم وزاره الصحه
الصوماليه ومنظمه الصحه العالميه ومنظمه
الامم المتحده للطفوله اليونس
ف كانت منظمه الصحه العالميه قد حذرت من
ان نحو 100 الف شخص في الصومال يواجهون
مستويات كارثيه من الجوع بسبب اسوا موجه
جفاف تضرب المنطقه منذ اربعين عاما وتسبب
تراجع الامطار في خمسه مواسم متتاليه
باجزاء من كينيا واثيوبيا والصومال تسبب
بنفوق الماشيه وتدمير المحاصيل واجبار
اكثر من مليون شخص على مغادره ديارهم بحثا
عن الطعام والماء والامل كل الامل ان
تتضاعف الجهود لتجنيد الصومال ومنطقه
القرن الافريقي كارثه انسانيه غير مسبوقه
تلوح في الافق دمتم بخير والى اللق
[موسيقى]
اء